hi I'm Matt Welch for recent TV I'm at
Freedom Fest in Las Vegas with Jeffrey
Tucker of lays fair books nice to see
you sir um you have developed an
interest in giving the talk here if I'm
not mistaken in a Bitcoin what does what
it was really you'd think to be more
interested at that freedom fest in
Bitcoin but there hasn't been that much
because it's kind of new it's only four
years old so we held a special panel it
was packed standing room only only 50
minutes to cover this gigantic topic but
we had fun and everybody's interested
there's so many questions and so many
issues to do with the Queen after all
we're talking about reinventing the
world's monetary system essentially you
know from up you know the ground up on
market basis that's a gigantic subsidy
subject are they gonna even be in
business by December of this year or
they're getting a Bitcoin and then so
you know one of the things I really try
to point out is that Bitcoin isn't
really a business firm or a business
right it's an open source protocol
really it's just math so in that sense
it's just ingenious it's a peer-to-peer
cryptic cryptographically protected
distributed network currency unit
invented by a guide nobody knows so you
talk about an implausible you know item
how did this possibly succeed but it did
it after two years after its inception
it our dollar parity now two years later
we're seeing enterprises develop all
over the world most of the big
enterprises that are developing around
Bitcoin as an open source protocol are
us-based but most of the intense
interest in bitcoin is around the world
China and Russia and Latin America is
huge and all over Africa most of the
unbanked two parts of the world that are
kind of excluded from the existing
matrix of government you know currency
exchange of the credit card system are
very interested in Bitcoin because it is
a peer-to-peer currency system what is
the kind of practical interest or
practical import of this thing this new
way of doing things the sidestepping of
the official gateway well there's two
aspects to Bitcoin that are both
combined
they challenged our understanding of
money because it's both a currency and a
payment system combined into one so the
payment system aspect of it is
especially appealing because it allows
you to exchange real property anywhere
in the world between any two people at
virtually no fees whatsoever so it's
paypal with its own dollars yeah said it
floats against the dollar right so it's
not a fixed relationships people
complain a bit because volatile well
yeah big surprise is new the amazing
thing is that it's you know today it's
valued at a hundred dollars it's a
remarkable thing allows me to transmit
real property all around the world with
just a click from my smartphone you
can't do that with gold really and you
can't do it with dollars without using
intermediaries that's the key bitcoin is
just me and you trading stuff and as
such it's a threat to at least some some
governments and regulatory authority it
didn't come about the way government's
like currencies to come about you know
they like him to be studied and
academics to come up with monetary
policies and for people to come out with
position papers and for them to float up
to the top so the philosopher king and
the Fed can implement the policy and so
on satoshi nakamoto who invented Bitcoin
didn't do it that way he just dumped it
out on an open source for over 30 years
by currency use it if you like it you
see a lot of conflict with this we're
devoting an upcoming issue on sort of do
it yourself versus the man these
technological workarounds 3d gun
printing as an example there's plenty of
them you know even food trucks in some
way is an example is this a constant
conflict we're going to be staying in
the 21st century I don't like that you
brought this up because you know
libertarians have a sort of a problem we
get convinced of the ideas that would
then we don't know what to do with
ourselves well we can read books and
read books and read books and support
this Canada to that candidate you know
but what else what else is there to life
and part of what you're referring to is
do-it-yourself libertarianism is the
same fazool emphasis i think i'm
building the institutions and structures
and enterprises that can kind of create
a new world of liberty despite the
existence of the vibes and state and i
think it's an exciting new strategic
mission for libertarians it's about time
it's like stage 2 if you know what i
mean you know it's like bill building
building out a parallel universe that is
interesting and it's a demonstration
project if you look at the history of
liberty that's always
part of the project in a way the
founders you know before the American
Revolution had large institutions in
churches and community organizations out
all kinds of clubs and everything like
that and you look at Russia you know it
wasn't the case that everybody's sort of
a bade the state and then one day the
state went away no it was a long decades
of sort of breaking bad you know went
into it you know and building up new
structures and liberty until the state
gets weaker and weaker less and less
effective and then the Liberty based
institutions begin to take over I think
that's where we're starting to see in
this country whether it's with
homeschooling or Bitcoin or you know
marijuana distribution or you know
whatever enterprises and kind of
do-it-yourself libertarianism I think
it's particularly exciting for
libertarians because it gives us
something to do besides just sort of
politically agitating support candidates
this is kind of boring actually you know
well on that lot boring note we'll wrap
it up here jeff tucker thank you very
much for joining us talking about
Bitcoin and elsewise i'm at wells for
recent TV thank you very much
you